let's now take the definite integral
from two to four of six plus x squared
over X to the third power DX and first
this might seem pretty daunting I have
this rational expression but if we just
rewrite this it might jump out at you
how this could be a little bit simpler
so this is equal to the integral from 2
to 4 of 6 over X to the 3rd power plus x
squared over X to the 3rd power DX I
just separated this numerator out I just
divided each of those terms by X to the
3rd power and this I could rewrite this
is equal to the integral from 2 to 4 of
6 X to the negative 3 power that's that
first term there and x squared divided
by X to the 3rd well that is going to be
1 over X so plus 1 over X DX now this is
going to be equal to let's take the
antiderivative of the different parts
and we're going to evaluate that at 4
and we're going to evaluate that at 2
and we're going to find the difference
between this express the antiderivative
valuated at 4 and a 2 now what is the
antiderivative of 6 X to the negative 3
well here once again we can just use we
could use as a power rule for taking the
antiderivative or it's the reverse of
the derivative power rule we know that
if we if we're taking the integral of x
to the n DX the antiderivative of that
is going to be X to the n plus 1 over n
plus 1 and if we were just taking an
indefinite integral there would be some
plus C the reason why we don't put the
plus C's here is when you when you
evaluated both both bounds of
integration the C would cancel out
regardless of what it is so we don't
really think about the C much when we're
taking definite integrals but let's
apply that to 6 X to the negative third
power so it's going to be we're going to
take X to the negative 3 plus 1 so it's
X to the negative 2 and so we're going
to divide by negative 2 as well
of course we had that six out front from
the get-go so that's the antiderivative
6x to the negative 3 power and what's
the antiderivative of 1 over X you might
be tempted to use the same idea right
over here you might be tempted to say
alright well the antiderivative of X to
the negative 1 which is the same thing
as 1 over X would be equal to X to the
negative 1 plus 1 over negative 1 plus 1
but what is negative 1 plus 1 it is 0 so
this doesn't fit this property right
over here but lucky for us there is
another property and we went the other
way when we were first taking
derivatives of natural log functions the
antiderivative of 1 over X or X to the
negative 1 is equal to sometimes you'll
see it written as natural log of X plus
C and sometimes and I actually prefer
this one because you could actually
evaluate it for negative values is to
say the absolute value the natural log
of the absolute value of X and this is
useful because this is defined for
negative values not just positive values
the negative the natural log of X is
only defined for positive values of X
when you take the absolute value now it
could be negative or positive values of
X and it works the derivative of this is
indeed 1 over X now it's not so relevant
here because our bounds of integration
are both positive but if both of our
bounds of integration were negative you
could still do this by just reminding
yourself that this is the natural log of
absolute value of X so this we could say
is plus the natural log of the absolute
value of X it's not a bad habit to do it
and if everything is positive well the
absolute value of X is equal to X and so
what is this going to be equal to this
is equal to let's evaluate everything at
4 and actually before I even evaluate at
4 what's 6 divided by negative 2 that's
negative 3 so if we evaluated at 4 it's
going to be negative 3 over 4 squared 4
to the negative 2 is 1 over 4 squared
and then plus the natural log of the we
could say the absolute value of 4 but
the absolute value of 4 is just 4
the abbe the natural log of four and
from that we're going to subtract
everything evaluated at two so let's do
that so if we evaluated it - it's going
to be negative three over two squared so
2 to the negative 2 is 1 over 2 squared
over 2 squared plus the natural log of
the absolute value of positive 2 is once
again it's just 2 and so what does this
give us so let's try to simplify it a
little bit so this is negative 3/16 we
do that same color so this is going to
be equal to negative negative 3
sorry not negative 3/16 it's got to be
very careful sorry yes sorry it isn't
hatest 3/16 for some reason my brain
start thinking 4 to the 3rd power
negative 3/16 plus natural log of 4 and
then this right over here is negative
3/4 negative 3/4 to do that same color
this right over here is negative 3/4 we
have this negative sign out front that
we're going to have to distribute so the
negative of negative 3/4 is plus 3/4
plus 3/4 and then we're going to
subtract remember we're distributing
this negative sign the natural log the
natural log of 2 and what is this equal
to
alright so this is going to be equal to
and I'm now going to switch to a neutral
color so let's add these two terms that
don't involve the natural log and let's
see if we have a common number 3 over 4
is the same thing that is the same thing
as we multiply the numerator and
denominator by 4 that is 12 over 16 and
so you have negative 3/16 negative 3 16
plus 12 16 will give you nine sixteenths
9/16 and then we're going to have the
ones that do involve the natural log
natural log of 4 minus the natural log
of 2 so we could write this plus the
natural log of 4
- the natural log of - and you might
remember from your logarithm properties
that this over here this is the same
thing as the natural log of 4 divided by
2 this comes straight out of your
logarithm properties and so this is
going to be the natural log of 2 natural
log of 2 so we deserve a little bit of a
drum roll now this is all going to be
equal to this is going to be equal to
the natural log the sr9 over 16 plus the
natural log of 2 plus the natural log of
2 and and we are done